et qu'amélie chili sociologue
spécialiste de l'iran bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
l'iran était victime très tôt dépit des
mines coronavirus aucun confinement n'a
été imposée puis il ya ces activités
économiques qui reprennent ce week-end
comment est perçue cette annonce par la
population alors effectivement le
confinement qui a eu cours en iran ne
ressemble en rien aux nôtres très
rapidement donc il faut rappeler que le
premier cas avéré coronavirus l'a été le
19 février donc c'est à la fin du mois
de février qu on a commencé à voir des
écoles des universités des cinémas des
lieux de culte est refermé et puis voir
imposer le télétravail dans les
administrations par contre il n'y avait
pas en tant que tel d'interdiction de
déplacement individuel ce n'est qu'à
partir du 25 mars
qu'on voit apparaître une interdiction
de circuler d'une ville à l'autre
interdiction qui est quand même malgré
tout très peu encadré mais assez pour
des raisons qui sont à la fois
économique ça a été soulignée évidemment
et pour des raisons culturelles qui sont
indéniables étant donné que sa paire de
nous a perdu jour de l'an qui est la
plus importante en iran et qui dure deux
semaines et qui traditionnellement veut
qu'on est en premier lieu voir la
personne de la famille la plus âgée
ensuite sept personnes accompagnent
roues pour aller voir la moins âgée et
ainsi de suite donc culturellement ça
aurait été impossible à mettre en place
et il en va de même d'ailleurs pour ce
qui concerne les décès même si les
autorités en faire en sorte dans le
cadre et les enterrements comme ça peut
être le cas chez nous force est
d'admettre que sur la totalité du
territoire ces interdictions et ses
encadrements ne sont pas respectés de la
même façon et puis bien évidemment et on
parle on en parlera encore un petit peu
si vous le souhaitez il y à cette
fameuse 7e reste problématique
économique
il a été question dans ce petit
reportage de retranscrit
mission des sanctions ce n'est pas
exactement le cas parce que les
sanctions donc jamais été levé
parce qu'elle incessamment neutraliser
mais si vous voulez on pourra développer
c'est un petit peu plus tard justement
aujourd'hui la reprise économique c'est
une nécessité pour le pays l'économie
est mise à mal on vient d'en parler le
chômage explose est ce que la république
islamique
redoutant soulèvement populaire alors
clairement aujourd'hui on se pose la
question de savoir comment ces
manifestations pourraient avoir recours
de façon plus violentes qu'elles ont
déjà été par exemple ou un d'octobre
dernier étant donné la situation c'est à
dire que éventuellement pour après pain
pour la période d'après traitement du
virus d'après lé après la crise
notamment des crises sanitaires
éventuellement la question se posera en
l'état l'a tout de suite c'est
impossible mais ça paraît quand même
assez peu probable donc il faut pas
oublier que l'économie est extrêmement
mise à mal avec une inflation qui tourne
autour de 40% que le prix du baril les à
33 dollars alors que des experts
expliquent il faudrait qu'il soit entre
90 et 95 $ pour permettre d'établir des
plans d'équipement médicaux pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire
il ya aussi toutes ces demandes de
l'iran par exemple au fmi pour pouvoir
avoir un prêt qui permettrait justement
à la fois de traiter la crise elle-même
et de traiter les conséquences
économiques de cette crise il ya une
demande de levée de sanction d'ailleurs
pour laquelle d'ailleurs les états unis
glissement et se mettre en porte-à-faux
par rapport aux décisions de la cour
internationale de justice mais oui il ya
quand même certains petits points qui
peuvent être intéressants comme par
exemple le fait que le luxembourg a
décidé de débloquer 1,6 milliard de
dollars de dollars 8 d'avoir gelé
iranien la demande de washington
savoir qu'ils avaient été violés l'avait
été dans le cadre d'une implication
supposée dans les attentats du 11
septembre ce qui n'a absolument rien à
voir avec jacques city way donc voilà il
ya un certain nombre de mesures qui
commencent à se débloquer tout ça avec
évidemment cette demande
à l'initiative de la cérémonie qui est à
la tête de la banque centrale iranienne
pour pouvoir obtenir des fonds du fmi
pour l'instant c'est toujours non mais
ils sont encore bon espoir de voir la
décision de shoushi d'un mot assez
rapidement les ultra conservateurs
dénoncent une mauvaise gestion de la
crise par hassan rohani est ce que vous
pensez qu'il profite de cette crise pour
tenter de reprendre le pouvoir est ce
qu'elles ont des chances de récupérer ce
pouvoir toujours incessamment tous ceux
qui ont intérêt en fait à voir l'actuel
gouvernement chanceler viennent utiliser
tout événement tout élément pour venir
déstabiliser en fait l'administration en
place
cela vaut pour les ultra conservateurs à
l'intérieur et ça vaut aussi pour les
puissances étrangères qui voit en
livrant une administration hostile par
exemple le les discours néo
conservateurs tourner en règle générale
autour de l'argument selon lequel rend
les ics donc le chef de l'état le guide
suprême serait assis sur une fortune de
plus de 84 millions de dollars et
pourrait utiliser pour gérer cette crise
sanitaire ou encore le fait que si on
levait les sanctions l'argent irait non
pas à eau la gestion de la crise
sanitaire mais bien plutôt entre les
mains des gardiens de la révolution
donc oui évidemment il ya toujours une
récupération que ce soit en interne ou
par l'extérieur de problèmes qui sont
plus ou moins mal géré mais ça c'est je
pense absolument partout pareil merci
beaucoup avait laissé les sociologues
spécialistes de lait renversé après
temps de répondre à nos questions sur
leur défense